six thousand miles from tokyo
and bradley sinden's first taekwondo
coach shares every torso punch and head
kick
of his ultimately unsuccessful quest for
gold
martin baker spotted the youngster's
talent when he was only four years old
and helped him become one of the best in
the world
covered restrictions prevented martin
from being in tokyo to watch
but that didn't make the agonising
defeat any less emotional
i'm gutted at the moment but
after he's got his medal in his calm
down i mean i've jumped to that flag
you know which is a big achievement what
he's done
but i know what badly wanted and he's
never happy
if he's not got the gold medal he's not
happy with silver
back at home in doncaster bradley's
family were left with mixed emotions
when we were watching him your stomach's
churning you feel quite sick actually
you know
i don't think either of us have eaten
today
um because that adrenaline's flowing and
it's slowing for bradley wanting him to
do well
and it didn't in the well he did do well
he did fantastic came away with silver
we know we'll be sad about it we're sad
bradley is now
only the second man ever to win an
olympic taekwondo medal for team gb
along with one of his childhood heroes
litali mohammed
this club in london it seems that he's
going to be just as inspirational for
the next crop of olympic hopefuls
it was really good but then at the end i
was really sad because
they lost he tried his best even when he
lost
and and i think he was working hard
no no no no no no and the good news for
these young taekwondo players
and for bradley is that they only have
to wait three years not four
for the next olympics in paris fraser
moored
sky news